in the last video we started with these
parametric equations X is equal to 3
cosine of T and Y is equal to 2 sine of
T and doing a little bit of algebra we
were able to remove the parameter and
turn it into an equation that we
normally associate with an ellipse we
got x squared over 9 plus y squared over
4 is equal to 1 and we graphed it and
I'll do that actually I have it from the
previous we graphed it and we got
something that looked like that right
there and then we said well why don't we
always just represent it like this well
this right here this equation that's
just a just in terms of X and y it just
represents the shape it doesn't
represent the actual path that let's say
that that T represents an object's point
an object's position at some place in
time and we went over that and as time
progressed we went around around the
ellipse in that case and as time goes
forward we kept going around this
ellipse but this begs the question is
this the only set of parametric
equations that when we do a little bit
of algebra gives this path can we think
of another set that gives that that
would also when you do the algebra get
here and I think we can so let's try a
couple I mean we could do a whole whole
bunch I'm actually maybe we will do a
whole bunch of them just to see that
there at what you'll see is that there's
actually an infinite number of
parametric equations that have this path
so one could be X is equal to 3 cosine
of of 2t and the other one is Y is equal
to 2 sine of 2t like we did in the last
video let's solve for cosine of 2t and
solve for sine of 2t so we just have to
divide both sides of this is equal both
sides of this top equation by 3 you get
x over 3 is equal to cosine of 2t divide
both sides of this equation by 2 you get
Y over 2 is equal to sine of 2t and
we'll use the same trig identity as we
did before when we did this problem
we said that sine squared of t plus
cosine squared of T is equal to one
well that's true so is this let me see
if that's true then we can also say that
sine squared of 2t plus cosine squared
of 2t is equal to one
in fact sine squared of anything here
plus cosine squared of anything as long
as it's the same anything as we put here
I can't have a 2t here and a 3t here but
if this is a two and this is a two then
that's always going to be equal to one
you can just fill in the blank because
this is always going to be the same
angle so if this is true we can then
just take this and substitute it in for
cosine of 2t and take the Y over 2 and
substitute in for sine of 2t and we get
C sine of 2t squared becomes Y over two
squared plus cosine of 2t is x over
three squared it equals one and that is
exactly what we had to begin with that
is the same thing as x squared over nine
I'm just switching the order here plus y
squared over four is equal to one so
they both both of these parametric
equations both sets of parametric
equations have the exact same path so
how are they different let's see if we
were to take so what in the previous
video we we took this yellow one
actually I rewrote it here and we did a
little table and we plotted the points
that it hits as you go around the circle
so let's do the same thing for our new
set no just since I lost it let me write
the two equations here was X is equal to
three cosine of 2t and Y is equal to two
sine of 2t they make a little table
the table there we go
and we're going to have a tea I'm going
to have an x and a y and let's pick the
same values of t zero PI over two and pi
when T is zero cosine of two times zero
that's cosine of zero which is 1 times 3
it's 3 when T is equal to PI over 2 2
times pi over 2 is PI cosine of PI over
2 is minus 1 minus 1 times 3 is minus 3
when T is equal to PI cosine of 2 times
pi is 2 pi cosine of 2 pi same thing as
cosine of zero we've so that's 1 1 times
3 is 3 and then on the Y side when T is
equal to 0 that's the same thing as sine
of 2 times 0 sine of zero 0 times 0 2 is
that's 0 PI over 2 sine of 2 times pi
over 2 that's the same thing as sine of
PI that's also 0 0 times 2 is 0 and then
PI sine of 2 pi well that's also 0 so
here we get a bunch of zeros so what
happened here let me do it in different
colors so in our first situation so they
both we established that both of both
this set of parametric equations and
this set of parametric equations they
both have the same overall I guess we
could say shape of their path they're
both this ellipse but we see what we saw
in the previous video is when you plot
these points at time T equals 0 we will
write this this point right here is that
right there and then at T is equal to PI
over 2 we got right there and then at T
is equal to PI we got over here and we
did that to establish that the direction
of motion if these parametric equations
really are describing some type of
motion would be counterclockwise now
what happens in this scenario so when T
is equal to
zero we're still at the point three zero
so they they at least at T equals zero
you can kind of view them as starting at
the same point if we assume we're
starting at T equals zero you don't have
to start at T equals zero I did that a
little bit in the last video but you can
start at T equals minus a Google or T
equals minus affinity so you don't
necessarily have a start point but if we
assume T is equals zero is the start
point you could say that they both start
there then at we pick a new color that I
haven't used yet then at T is equal to
PI over two where are we where minus 3 0
we get all the way oh that's the same
color I used before we let me see this
let me do this color we're here now
notice in the first one when we went
from T equals 0 to T equals PI over 2 we
went from here to there we went kind of
a quarter of the way around the ellipse
but now when we went from T equals 0 to
PI over 2 where did we go
we went halfway around the ellipse we
went all the way from there all the way
over there and likewise when we went
from T equals PI over 2 to T equals PI
with this set of parametric equations we
went another quarter of the ellipse we
went from there to there but here when
we go from T equals PI over 2 to T
equals PI we go all of this way we go
back to the back to the beginning part
of our lips so what you see is is that
this set of parametric equations has the
exact same shape of its path as this set
of parametric equations except it's
going around it at twice as fast of a
rate for every time you know when when
when T increases by PI over 2 here we go
by we kind of go a quarter way around
the ellipse but when T equal increases
by PI over 2 here we go half way around
the ellipse so the thing to realize and
I know I've touched on this before is
that even though both of these sets of
parametric equations when you do the
algebra they can kind of be converted
into this shape you lose the
formation about where our particle is
around as it's rotating around the
ellipse or how fast it's rotating around
the ellipse and that's why you need
these parametric equations we can even
set up a parametric equation that goes
in the other direction if you instead of
having these and you know I encourage
you to play with that but if you instead
of this if you just put a minus sign
right here cosine of minus T and two
sine of minus T instead of doing going
in that direction it would go in this
direction it would go in a clockwise
direction so one thing that you've
probably been thinking from the
beginning is okay Ike was able to go
from my parametric equations to this
equation of ellipse in terms of just X&Y
can you go back the other way could you
go from this to this and I think you
might realize now that the answer is no
because there's no way just with the
information that you're given here to
know that you should go to this
parametric equation or this parametric
equation or any of an infinite number of
parametric equations I mean anything of
the form X is equal to 3 cosine 3 cosine
of of really you know anything times T
and Y is equal to 3 times cosine of as
long as it's the same anything I drew
the two swig Lee Marx the same as long
as these two things are the same then
you will have they'll both converge to
this shape so if you have the shape you
don't know what parametric equation you
can go back to you could make up one but
you don't know which one you'll go back
to and just to kind of hit the point
home of kind of making up a parametric
equation sometimes that's asked asked of
you so let's just do a very simple
example let's start with a normal
function of X so let's say that we have
the equation y is equal to x squared
plus X I just made it up and let's say
that you are asked to turn this into a
parametric equation and this is often a
very hard thing for people because there
is not one right answer you can turn it
into an arbitrary number of parametric
equations I could just make do something
really crazy and arbitrary I could say X
is
when I have Y defined explicitly in
terms of X like this I can make X enter
anything in terms of T I could say it's
cosine of T minus the natural log of T I
just made that up
that's just a random thing but then if X
is this then Y is going to be equal to I
just substitute this back in cosine of T
minus Ln of t squared plus cosine of t
minus Ln of T and we've done we just
converted this into a parametric
equation or a set of parametric
equations I could have also just written
x is equal to X is equal to T and then
what would y equal Y would be equal to T
squared plus plus T now you might say
well what's the difference between this
parametric equation and this parametric
equation well they're both going to have
the same shape of their paths it's going
to be something like a parabola but the
rate and the direction with which they
progress on those paths will be very
very different and it's actually a very
interesting thing to think about there
are some paths that you could take where
let's say that the you could you could
set up a parametric equation let's say
that the shape is you know everything
we've done so far we've always been
going in one direction but you can have
a there are scenarios and maybe if I
have time I'll make a video and this
isn't what you know where let's say the
shape of the path is some type of I
don't know let's say it's a it's a
circle of some kind I'm just going to
that's not this so I'm doing a
completely different example right now
I'm just kind of sometimes you know with
the ellipses we had paths that went
counterclockwise and then pass that one
counter clockwise you can also have
paths that kind of oscillate in between
move around move back and forth along
the thing so there's all sorts of
parametric equations that you can define
and you can you know you can say if T
goes from this to this you're use this
set of parametric equations if it's
another set of T's using another one so
there's all sorts of crazy things you
can do to say what happens as you move
along the path so the difference not
that this is the path of that this is
actually more of a parabola but the
difference between this and this is how
you move along this shape anyway I hope
you found that vaguely useful